thank you very much Michael and and
thanks to the entire department for
inviting me here especially on the
occasion of a lecture that bears fields
name it's really an amazing contribution
you've made in the early years of this
institute putting together this group of
people or the kernel of this group of
people that led to what it is today I
was convinced again today of what a
fantastic environment it is I got to see
a good number of young people that I've
never met before and it's amazing the
range of activities that that go on here
now like many of you here I'm interested
in how neural circuits shape the
behavior of animals and of course this
is a very large question I'm going to
talk today specifically about the
control of defensive behaviors and we
would like to ultimately reverse
engineer the system somehow and
understand how the brain goes all the
way from early visual signals in the
retina through various intermediate
stages - oops - the control of motor
output and this is of course a very
large problem today I can only give you
something like a research plan with some
intermediate results but I hope to give
you a sense of how we'd like to go about
to connect these various stages of
organization of the of the nervous
system but I want to start out with some
kind of meta level comments on how to
choose a research subject and this might
be interesting to some of the younger
members of the of the audience let me
see if I can just do it this way so how
do you pick a problem how do you choose
what animal to work on and what behavior
to work on given that there are
thousands of choices on both the rows
and columns of that matrix and
there is a principled framework for this
that emerged in the 20th century that
suggests that for every brain function
for every kind of behavior you might be
interested in there is some organism
some animal that does it best
and that you should pick that organism
and study its specializations for these
abilities that it has evolved and that
led of course to a beautiful a spectrum
of studies on the behaviors of barn owls
which I'll mention again in a moment
famous for their auditory localization
and the bats that do echolocation and
bees that communicate by dancing and
birds that can learn a song for a
lifetime and this is really a fantastic
body of work that has been stimulated by
this this idea that you should choose
the animal that best exemplifies what
you would like to understand about the
brain now in recent years this lofty
principle has run into some issues to do
with research funding because the
official line now is that you can only
work on four animals and I realized that
some of you work outside of this narrow
spectrum but you have to increasingly
justify why it's reasonable to do so and
of course there are good arguments for
working on these for animals molecular
genetic tools being one of them but
obviously this runs into the whole
philosophy of neuroethology in a serious
way how to deal with that so some of us
have developed what I would call reverse
neuroethology along the lines of reverse
genetics so suppose you are forced to
work with a particular animal you can
still ask what is the behavior that this
animal does best
what is it famous for and then focus on
that and in that way
I hope that you're in a similar corner
maybe as the original neurologists so
let me give you an example
this is of course a paradigmatic example
of neuroethology approach the barn owl
has evolved these these fantastic
features incredibly silent wings and a
ruff of feathers that amplifies the
sound and big eyes that capture whatever
photons are left in the environment why
in order to hunt these little creatures
by their auditory system alone and
wonderful progress has been made in
understanding the brain of this animal
that's adapted to that task but you
should also ask yourself who forced the
barn owl to evolve all these fantastic
abilities and of course it's the little
rodent down here because it is so good
at running away from barn owls such that
in fact when in dim light there's no way
the owl will catch this road because it
will escape based on its visual
capabilities and even in complete
darkness it's a difficult task so the
idea is take the same picture but focus
on the other end of the photograph and
work on the ability of small rodents to
run away from aerial threats they're
extremely good at that and you can
replicate the behavior in the laboratory
we put the mouse in a small arena that
has in one corner a nest which the
animal perceived as a shelter and we
cover the roof of the arena with a
display monitor and other monitor we put
a simulation of an approaching owl you
don't have to be terribly realistic
about this in fact an expanding dark
disk is very effective as I'll show you
in a moment so we give the animal about
five minutes or so to explore the arena
and get comfortable with it and then at
some point we present this expanding
disc on the roof of the monitor here
we're looking into the side of the arena
there's the nest in the corner and this
mouse is a standard laboratory Mouse
it's come straight from the breeder its
ancestors have not seen an owl for about
50 generations or so so you might worry
does it still have the innate abilities
it's also the first time the animal is
in this box and obviously the first time
that it sees what's gonna happen on the
monitor you'll see this dark spot
appearing up here but my student MELAS
has put a little icon down here so we
can see better when that happens so
let's watch the animal behavior yeah I
think we'll get another repeat of the
movie and if you look closely you'll
find that it takes about 0.2 or 0.25
seconds from the appearance of the spot
on the ceiling to when the animal is
crouched and accelerating towards the
nest now half the time the animals do
something different and that's
illustrated here this is a different
Mouse again the first exposure to the
arena first exposure to the stimulus
when I first saw this I didn't have the
convenient icon in the bottom right and
that was convinced that the video had
stopped running somehow but obviously
the the mouse is suspended here in space
and time its tail is sticking out
straight it's difficult to see any kind
of movement when we go and check they
are still breathing but just barely
anyway it's still monitoring the
environment and eventually becomes
unstuck when the stimulus stops and
slinks off into the corner any case so
this this happens 100% of the time
you've put an animal into this box and
expose it to this looming stimulus and
these are very primitive Aoife grams
where every row of the plot is one
animal this is the time axis the
expanding spots start at time zero when
you see a red bar that's escaped to the
nest when you see a purple bar that's
the prolonged freezing and when you see
a light blue bar that's the animals
raring up and looking around and in this
exploratory posture the behavior is
quite sensitive to the visual properties
of the visual stimulus so for example if
you just dim the ceiling
let's say you put a big disc on and make
the disc dimmer you get far fewer
reactions mostly you get raring
reactions the animals are curious about
what happens on the ceiling but and
occasionally and late you get escape
reactions if you produce this stimulus
which also has an advancing dark edge
but it's advancing inward rather than
outward again much reduced escape
responses so we've wondered of course
why do the animals 3 sometimes and
escape some other times and it turns out
to depend on the conditions in which you
do this behavioral test in particular if
you offer the animals a shelter in the
way that I showed you a moment ago then
about half the time they will freeze and
half the time they will escape and in
fact the same animal will make different
choices on different trials whereas if
you don't offer them that that shelter
the animals will freeze almost all the
time and run away only rarely and this
you know makes sense if there's no place
of safety then your best choice is
probably to try and fade into the
background and hope that the owl hasn't
spotted you yet we've wondered whether
the animals make this choice about
escaping or freezing at the moment that
the threat appears do they assess their
environment look around and then decide
to run to shelter or is something else
involved so here's a that you should
find interesting so we're looking again
into the arena this is a slightly bigger
box here's the animal here's this
shelter it looks transparent to you but
it's gonna be opaque to the mouse it's
like a red plastic shelter everything is
done and infrared illumination so any of
the lights you see here are not visible
to the animal but we will project a
stimulus from the above onto the screen
which is visible from below so you have
to pay attention here because various
things are gonna happen the animal will
walk over into the corner then something
Funky's going to happen to its shelter
and then a stimulus expanding spot
stimulus happens right here so are you
ready
okay so again this happens every time we
try this experiment with different
animals the impression is that the
animals have kind of preformed an escape
plan
maybe I'm over interpreting but the
impression is that they know where the
shelter is at the time that the threat
appears and are just kind of recalling
that that knowledge of the environment
ought to be okay we would like now to
explore some of the questions that come
up in this in this context these are
some of the topics we're working on now
there's a question of detection how is
the threat identified what are the
circuits the neurons that that extract
this signal from the visual input
there's a decision here between two very
different behaviors right freezing means
staying as still as possible escaping
run as fast as possible so they're kind
of diametrically opposite options where
is that decision made how is it made and
then how is that decision controlled we
know now that the choices that depend on
the animals experience in the arena it
also depends on other aspects of its
internal state and we'd also might like
to know how that happens as well in
practice we're working on three
different brain areas at this moment on
visual signals in the retina because
obviously that's where the visual
information comes from we're studying
beginning to study signals and superior
colliculus we believe that it's involved
in the downstream processing of these
threat signals and then together with
David Anderson we're also interested in
what happens in the hypothalamus because
there's some indication that this area
is involved in the modulation or control
of these defensive behaviors okay let's
start in the front at the front end in
the in the retina as you know the retina
is this layered neural circuit at the
back of the eye it stretches from
photoreceptor cells
to retinal ganglion cells the output
neurons their axons form the optic
nerves there are bipolar cells that
connect photoreceptors to yang
themselves and in addition there are
lateral connections from horizontal
cells and this outer layer synapses and
amacrine cells at this inner layer of
synapses these five classes of cells are
subdivided into many more subtypes of
neurons we think there are about 70 or
80 types of neuron in the retina that
can be distinguished based on their
shape their structure their synaptic
connectivity and increasingly Russian
profiles the bottom layer the retinal
ganglion cells the output population
alone is composed of about 30 types of
retinal ganglion cell each type
completely tiles the visual field and is
busy processing the visual signal in its
own way and extracting certain features
and sending that particular information
about that particular feature on to the
brain this area of retinal neuroscience
has really been a turbocharged that
would say like many other parts of
neuroscience by the advent of molecular
genetic tools that allows in particular
to select certain subtypes of neuron in
the retina and mark them either to
visualize them with fluorescent proteins
or to modify them in one way or another
and here we've benefitted tremendously
from a long collaboration with Josh
Saenz was here in the audience and who
contributed most of the mouse lines that
are available today for selectively
marking and the manipulation of retinal
neurons here for example are four
different lines of mice in which the
retinal ganglion cells are stained in
and you can see that they are distinct
in these vertical sections by where in
the inner plexiform layer they ramify
their dendrites these neurons ramified
the very top layer of these neurons
mostly in the middle between these two
red
and the location where a Gangnam cell
sends its dendrites determines which
types of bipolar cells and amacrine
cells it gets input from and ultimately
determines the visual computation of
that neuron performs so one can think
about the retina as being something like
30 visual processors all in one circuit
it really processes the image and about
30 different ways and sends those on to
the brain as population signals in the
optic nerve and in many of these cases
we understand what the neurons compute
and even what the circuits are by which
they do so and here are a few examples
we for example found that there's a type
of neuron that exists in many species
that responds selectively when an object
moves with a different trajectory from
the background of the object and this is
thought to highlight objects in the
presence of a movements that shifts the
entire image around and there's a good
understanding of the circuit involving
bipolar cells and amacrine cells and
ganglion cells and rectification and
inhibition that actually produces that
particular computation and there are
other examples of image computations for
which we can really write down neural
circuits we can verify the neural
circuits but actually injecting and
neurons and finding their synaptic
connectivity and we can also use those
neural circuits as mathematical models
to predict the response of this
particular retinal ganglion cell and in
many cases these models are getting very
good at producing the correct output
signals so today I want to talk about a
particular class of retinal ganglion
cells they're called the Alpha ganglion
cells and they exist in most are all
mammalian retinas and they were first
described in the cat retina by virtue of
being the biggest gang in cells in the
whole circuit so they tend to have large
cell bodies large dendrites thick axons
they stain strongly for neural filament
which is presumably a structural
component
of all these big processes they project
to both of the major visual pathways
they have very fast axonal conduction
and short response latency so when
something happens in the world
the first action potentials that tell
the brain about it are usually from
alpha retinal ganglion cells so we
wanted to understand this class of
gangue in cells better in the mouse
retina to try and see what role they
might play in encoding different kinds
of visual stimuli the key tool here was
another mouse line that Josh and
colleagues developed that expresses
query combination the locus of a gene
for a potassium channel subunit and the
particular reason why the potassium
channel subunits might be expressed in
alpha cells we don't understand at this
moment but we're just opportunistically
using it as a marker for this class of
neurons so this shows these neurons
labeled in the cui line for comparison
this is an antibody to neuro filament
and this is an antibody to another
protein called osteopontin which has
been closely associated with the alpha
retinal ganglion cells again through
work of Josh and colleagues so this has
allowed us now to go into the retina day
after day and record from alpha cells
and learn something and one afternoon
and apply what you learned the next
morning to change the experiment and so
on and this kind of ability to
repeatedly target the same neuron type
out of 80 possible ones makes a huge
difference in just your experimental
planning and in the way you learn things
about the object of interest and tell
you a little bit and next few minutes
what we learned about this class of
gangue in cells first of all the Alpha
cells in the mouse come in four
different types interesting if you look
at the cells face-on meaning you have
the retina and a flat mount under a
microscope and you look at their shapes
in this tangential plane they are almost
indistinguishable they all have a
characteristic alpha like morphology big
cell bodies thick
and rights and a pretty regular
dendritic tree branching outward but if
you record their signals in response to
visual stimuli they are very different
here we just put a small spot on the
center of the retina of the alpha gang
and cell and turn the spot off and on
and you find that there two types of
cells that are on cells they respond
when their light goes on and two types
that are off cells they respond when the
light turns off within each of the two
polarities you have one type that
responds in a sustained fashion meaning
they fire for the entire duration of the
light on and another type that fires in
a transient fashion only a brief burst
of spikes at the onset and vice versa on
the off side you similarly have a cell
with sustained responses and another
with transient responses now these are
just four examples but if you look at
the entire population of neurons that we
recorded they really do fall nicely into
these four categories based on the
dynamics of their light response so
these are firing rate as a function of
time when the spark goes off and on and
you can see tangent cells fire only
transiently and they're sustained elves
keep their firing rate up if you analyze
each of these by a couple of parameters
let's say the amount of decline of the
firing rate from the peak to the steady
level and also the decay time that it
takes for that then in a scatter plot
you find that the neurons fall into four
classes quite nicely that are separated
by these two parameters so from now and
I'm going to call these by their names
of transient of sustained on transient
unsustained identified by these
functional parameters it turns out that
these four classes that you identify
functionally are also different in their
shape morphologically I told you they
look the same when you look at them face
on but in a vertical section you see
they're different because the dendrites
of the four types of alpha cell ramify
in different at different levels of the
inner plexiform layer the on cells
ramify
at the bottom the off cells at the top
and that's expected it's a long known
result that the inner plexiform layer is
divided roughly into on signals in the
bottom half and off singles in the top
half but in addition you can see that
the transient neurons the ramify closer
to the middle of the inner plexiform
layer and sustained neurons closer to
the outside so even though the four
types are defined functionally they are
very clearly morphologically distinct
once you look at where their dendrites
ramified okay
another oddity that we encountered which
might be interesting to biophysicists is
that the action potential of these alpha
gang in cells has a strange shape when
you record extracellular ly usually
neurons have a action potential that
goes down and overshoots these four
types all have a little pre spike on the
shoulder of the rising phase and if you
turn down the temperature of the bath a
little bit the pre spike can actually
separate completely from the main action
potential this phenomenon is very
similar to something that was described
about 70 years ago in motor neurons and
we now understand where the spike shape
comes from and we think that the spike
begins at the axon initial segment which
is the most sensitive part of the neuron
and often there's a little bit down the
axon from the cell body then the current
that flows in at that point is used to
charge up the cell body bring it to
threshold and produce an action
potential there and in these large
neurons where the axon initial segment
is a little bit further away that can
take a few fractions of a millisecond
and the lead to this delay between the
first spike in the second spike so we
think what we're looking at is the early
spike of the axon initial segment
followed by a large action potential
that involves the cell body and
ultimately the dendrites so if that's
the case you might expect as indeed had
been observed in motor neurons that
sometimes the axon
segment fires but fails to charge the
cell body and in fact we found that this
does happen if you record with a cell
attached electrode that allows you to
get a high resolution on this action
potential you see that occasionally you
find a little spike but not the big
spike so these are occasions where we
think an action potential travels down
the nerve of the Skagen cell but fails
to invade the cell body and the rest of
the neuron this may be a detail but it
is of interest when you ask about the
cellular processing within the gang and
cell the fact that occasional action
potentials don't back propagate can make
a big difference of practical use is the
fact that we can now recognize these
alpha cells also in a blind
extracellular recordings for example on
multi electrode arrays where we don't
have a molecular marker that can be used
and ambiguous ly to identify them we can
now recognize them by their spike shape
okay let me move on to talk about what
these alpha cells do for the mouse
visual system what do they actually
encode about the visual world and let's
start again with some classical results
from cat alpha cells these date back
about fifty years to Christina and Ruth
Google and John Robson and they analyzed
the responses of cat retinal ganglion
cells with spatial sinusoid gratings and
they found interestingly that the at a
certain spatial frequency the neuron
gives the highest response but if you go
down in spatial frequency meaning
broader and broader fringes the response
declines by about a factor of two and
this is now associated we think of this
more in spatial terms rather than
spatial frequency terms as being a
consequence of center-surround
antagonism in the receptive field of
these ganglion cells so they respond to
light with one polarity in the center
and with the opposite polarity in the
surround and if you look at how sinusoid
gratings of different frequencies
interact with this kind of spatial
filter you get this sort of bandpass
response
a second feature that comes out of the
classic literature of alpha or Y selves
as they've been called is that their
response depends strongly on the phase
of the sinusoid grating so let's start
with the left-hand column which is more
of a generic type of retinal gang and
sell an excel in the cat if you put the
sinusoid grating on such that the
positive fringe is over the receptive
field Center you get a big response if
you put the sign so grating such as a
negative fringe of dark fringes over the
receptive field Center you get an
inverted response and if you shift the
grating to halfway in between such that
there's both dark and light over the
receptive field Center when you turn on
the grating you get nothing so this
concept or this kind of behavior is
called linear spatial summation it's as
though the gang and cell just counts the
total amount of light over its receptive
field Center and responds accordingly
and so in this experiment where you're
removing light from one side and adding
it to the other side there's no net
reaction very different for the Y selves
or the alpha cells I'm going to use the
two labels Angely for these neurons no
matter where you set the phase of the
grating you'll get a burst of spikes
when you turn the grating on or off even
in this situation where your Olympics
ighting half of the receptive field and
supposedly inhibiting the other half the
gang in cells still fires at both
transitions you now know that this
results from what are called nonlinear
subunits of the receptive field or more
biologically bipolar cells with
rectifying synapses so the gang is cell
receptive field Center is made up of
many bipolar cells and when you shine
light on one bipolar cell and take it
away from another bipolar cell of course
one gets excited and the other one
inhibited but because of this
rectification at the synapse only the
excitation goes through through the gang
and cell and will therefore make it fire
every time this signature of nonlinear
spatial summation has been taken
it's kind of a key characteristic of
alpha cells and has often served to
identify them what I want to ask now is
first of all do the mouse alpha cells
behave like cat alpha cells that kind of
paradigmatic historically defining alpha
cells and second if they do do these
properties make any difference for the
visual encoding of natural scenes so
let's first check whether the basic
spatial summation properties are the
same in the mouse ganglion cells let's
look at the antagonistic surround and
yes that happens in Mouse kangmin cells
as well if you start to if you flash a
spot of light on the gangue and cell and
you start with a small spot and
gradually increase it you begin with a
small response it grows and then
declines again that's plotted here
kickers firing rate as a function of
radius of the spot it grows at first
while the spot begins to fill the
receptive field center and then when the
spot encroaches in the surround it
declines again and the decline is about
a factor of two equivalent to what was
found in the alpha retinal ganglion
cells of the cat
so there is an antagonistic
center-surround interaction just as
described in the classic literature what
about the nonlinear subunits within the
center we can test that as was done
before with gratings so when we put a
grating on the receptive field Center
and carefully position it so that half
of the center is white and the other
half is black then we switch to the
other mode we invert the grating we get
the bursts of spikes from the Skagen
cell and another burst of spikes when we
switch back in another burst of spikes
and about 200 Hertz these are very
strong responses so yes it is possible
to drive these alpha ganglion cells by
removing light from one portion of the
receptive field and putting it on
another one we can make these bars finer
and finer and it continues to work until
eventually the bars get so fine that we
think the subunits in the receptive
field that bipolar cells can no longer
resolve the grating and
you stopped getting any responses so
both the spatial feature spatial
integration properties of gangman selves
the center-surround antagonism and the
nonlinear summation over subunits exist
in the mouse retina as well we'd like to
know now what these neurons encode about
the visual scene under real natural
conditions what do I mean by natural
conditions so we take movies of the
natural world and bring them back to the
laboratory and shine them on the retina
in the dish record from neurons some of
those conditions what are the movies one
type of movie is a mouse cam movie where
a tiny video camera gets placed on the
head of a mouse and we allow it to run
around in an arena with its friends as
you saw here and the other movie is a
simulation of a mouse where we put a
video camera on the end of a stick and
run it through the grass and in fact the
cinematographers in the audience are
sesh and so obviously we have you know
higher resolution movies from the
simulation where we can work with a big
video camera rather than a really tiny
one but remarkably the responses of
alpha gang itself so these two types of
movies are very similar and here they're
ill astray turd with raster graphs six
successive repeats of the identical
movie and the average firing rate as a
function of time throughout the movie in
grey it's kind of hard to see you can
see the standard error of the response
over trials same thing for the movie
obtained from the simulated so at this
point all we can say is that the gang in
cells fire a lot and they seem to be
strongly modulated firing rates of
several hundred Hertz so there's
obviously there's a lot of interesting
features in this movie that elicits
these gang in selves to say something to
the brain it's kind of neat to see how
they sustain selves for example the on
cells and the off cells are
complementary to each other
so again I'm plotting time throughout
the movie here and the firing rate of
the off sustain cells goes up in blue
and for the on sustain cells I've
plotted it downward in gray and you can
see how these two graphs interleaved
very nicely so that when the on cells go
up the off cells come down at vice-versa
it's as though these two neurons are
encoding you know complementary features
of the same signal they're really
encoding the same signal but with
opposite polarities and you can see a
similar interdigitating nice and fitted
situation for the off cells sorry for
the transient cells okay that's all fine
but what is it about the visual world
that the neurons are reporting can we
understand what the visual features are
that that they're telling the brain
about so the classic approach to
answering that question is to put
together a mathematical model that
calculates a prediction of the firing
rate from the movie and compare that to
the measured firing rate of the neuron
and if the prediction and the real
firing rate are close then you say
you've understood what the computation
is but here Brenna decided to do
something else first she asked what can
I do to the movie without affecting the
responses of the neurons so she's in a
way in a directed fashion asking what is
it about this movie of the natural world
that actually makes the neuron tick and
makes it change its response and so we
started with something really simple we
blurred the movie in a way that is
reflective of the mouse eye optics so
that we actually get the accurate amount
of blur and sharpness on the retina
correct and that made very little
difference and here's an example the
dotted line is the real response firing
rate as a function of time from a
particular alpha ganglion cell and the
solid blue line is the response to the
modified movie so very little difference
then she did something more dramatic and
inverted the movie turned it upside down
180 degrees and asked her what's the
response to that movie from the same
neuron and here's a comparison again
the original solid is the modified movie
here's a scatterplot one against the
other and you can see very little change
in the response from this major image
transformation and then she got more
courageous and said let's divide the
receptive field into Center and surround
and we'll take the center to be a
hundred micron radius and the surround
everything outside of there and let's
completely remove the spatial structure
in the surround and just calculate the
average intensity there and put that in
a new movie where the whole surround is
going cohesively average intensity again
very little difference in the response
of alpha retinal gang and cell and she
said let's just drop this around
entirely and only present the center
with a movie through a tiny mask like
that and again here's a comparison of
the original and modified scatter plot
it's very hard to see any difference in
the response of the retinal gang and so
finally this seems awfully crass but I
have to say it she removed the structure
from the center and just calculated the
average intensity in that 200 micron
radius and modulated the stimulus
accordingly and again there was very
little difference in how the gang in
cells responded to that now you might
say and I wondered is she doing
something wrong maybe she's really
always presenting that but fortunately
there are many other gang cells in the
retina that you could record from you
don't have to go for the fluorescent
ones and if you do it for a different
type of retinal ganglion cell in this
case and on a cell you get a completely
different response for example to the
rotated movie there's no not true for
every neuron in the retina okay so just
to bring this home here's a summary of a
larger population of neurons that we
analyzed I'm plotting the percent
correlation between the firing rate
under the modified movie and the firing
rate under the original movie if you
simply compare one example of the
with with another one meaning this is a
cross trial correlation you get
something like 85 or 90 percent and if
you then modify the movie by blurring it
rotating averaging this around leaving
this around out and averaging the center
you find that the correlation hardly
changes at all you always have something
like 70 or 80 percent correlation with
the original so all these modifications
leave the response of original gang and
so unaltered and that obviously serves
now to inform a mathematical model by
which we'll try to explain the response
in particular we know we only have to
pay attention to one variable as a
function of time maybe the average
intensity in the center we can
completely ignore spatial processing and
so let's do that let's try to predict
the firing rate from that one variable
and we started with the simplest model
you can think of an Ln model that
convolved the time course of this with a
linear filter and then takes the output
of that and runs it through a static
non-linearity and you can estimate both
the filter and the non-linearity by
standard methods from the data and
here's the result in black are the data
the measured firing rate of a gang and
cell under the movie and in red is the
prediction from this very simple model
and the prediction also has about 80%
correlation with the real response so
what happened to the nonlinear subunits
what happened to all that nonlinear
integration over space that is
paradigmatic for alpha retinal ganglion
cells well you can try to put that back
into the mathematical model so instead
of simulating the center sorry analyzing
the center only by averaging over the
entire region you can put in subunits
simulated bipolar cells and give them
their own nonlinearities and fit a model
of this type to the sponsors and what
you find is that it barely makes any
difference so to the right is the
correlation again for each of the four
alpha types the correlation of the model
with the data under a single variable
Center only and then as we go to the
left here we have 16w
and there's no discernible difference in
the quality of the fit so we can say now
that even though nonlinear spatial
integration is a characteristic of alpha
ganging cells that have been used to
identify them it really plays very
little role if any context of natural
scenes and I'm gonna skip over this in
and summarize a little bit what we've
learned about the alpha cells in in this
study first of all we found that they
come in four types that are symmetric to
on types two off types to transient we
found that the nonlinear summation of
alpha cells seems to play very little
role in encoding natural stimuli in fact
you can explain almost everything they
do by only looking at one pixel of the
image that's the size of the receptive
field Center this is useful to know
because the Alpha selves are thought to
be a prime pathway to both the superior
colliculus and to the thalamus and
cortex they obviously are very active
they're firing half the time learning
these natural scenes and so having a
quantitative mathematical model of what
these neurons encode is going to be
useful in thinking about processing now
so let me get back on to the
relationships to behavior and
particularly these defensive behaviors
we'd like to understand better how the
retinal ganglion cells are related to
these innate behaviors of the animal and
I should say that you know a big mystery
in the field a big question I would say
is why are there 30 types of retinal
ganglion cell why did Nature choose to
split the visual signal up into all
these differentiated pathways so early
on and one idea is that perhaps each of
these gang and cells is used for a
particular low-level kind of visual
behavior I mean there are lots of
low-level tasks we have to do like
opening and closing the pupil keeping
the eyes
centered
moving along with the environment
stabilizing ourselves relative to the
environment getting out of the way of
obstacles flinching away from branches
that are about to hit us in the face and
running away from owls if you're a mouse
so perhaps these many channels of visual
information are kind of adapted to take
care of some of these low-level tasks
already so to try and and map the
classes of gangman cells onto visual
behaviors we used an approach where we
we try to silence or remove gangue in
cells from the retina and ask what that
does to the responses or to the
reactions of the animal here we use two
different kinds of modifications one
makes use of this case Eng Cree line in
order to ablate classes of retinal
ganglion cells and we know that this
ablation involves the four Alpha types I
just talked about but we believe that
there are other neurons in the retina
that are affected as well so this is not
a completely clean and specific ablation
yet but there's an orthogonal ablation
we tried in which we remove the the
neurons that expressed choline as little
transferase these are starburst amacrine
cells that as many of you know are
involved in Direction selectivity of
retinal ganglion cells and so this
modification which I'll call the C
ablation will remove Direction
selectivity from seven different types
of retinal ganglion cell and now the
question is what are the effects of
these two oblations on looming reactions
for example or on other types of visual
behaviors that one could imagine either
of these two groups involved in the
looming reaction for example one of the
Alpha cells the off transient cell has
been called a looming detector we don't
quite believe that anymore because I
just told you that they respond to all
kinds of things just depending on the
intensity in that central pixel but
equally these other Direction selective
neurons might be involved in defining a
expanding the dark disk by recording the
motion of the different parts of the
edge of the disk so what are the effects
of making these two oblations on the
behavior of the animals so the K
ablation turns out reduces the looming
reactions by a large factor by about two
thirds or so both freezing and escaping
are affected by ablation of these
neurons whereas the other major ablation
whether you eliminate all the starburst
amacrine cells has no effect on the
behavior of the animal under looming
stimuli
now you might wonder did we just you
know generically destroy the retina
under these conditions so you want
another behavior ideally as a control
and here we use the up two motor
behavior but which animals try to turn
their head along with the direction of a
moving grating you can kind of ours of
the grating and this behavior is
completely unaffected under the K
ablation that affects alpha cells and
some other types of neurons whereas it's
reduced to zero under the C ablation
that affects the starburst amacrine
cells so we have kind of opposite
effects on the behavior of the these two
behaviors at least of the mouse from
these two different ablations and these
are both still rather crude ablations
but there's a sense that there's some
dissociation of the roles of different
gang in cells for four different
downstream behaviors for these low-level
behaviors so obviously we would like to
now refine these ablation so that we get
down to idea leasing Oh retinal gang and
cell types and understand better how
they feed these I mean in the last few
minutes say a little bit about how we're
going about investigating downstream
processing and this is only to give you
a sense of what we'd like to do there
are no hardware
here yet but obviously a decision has to
be made we're where to look next because
the retina projects to a dozen different
areas in the brain but the major
pathways are one to the lateral
geniculate and from there to the cortex
and the other to disapear colliculus so
we think that the cortex is not involved
or not necessary for the defensive
reactions in particular and here's an
anecdote that was told to me by John
watt sang a competitor I should say but
and the the anecdote is that he's been
working with a mouse that is
unencumbered by forebrain structures
like cortex and hippocampus it's a
result of a fortuitous Asian there's a
transcription factor emx one that comes
on when the cortex begins to develop and
as soon as that comes on this creel INEX
eliminate the ability of neurons to
divide so basically the precursor cells
can never form these structures and here
it looks like the technician dropped
part of the section but actually the
animal never had the top of its brain
nevertheless these animals react just
fine to looming stimuli and they can
even remember where the nest is so
something for Matt to ponder anyway so
we have a sense that the the other major
pathway is a more likely candidate and
we're now trying to follow the signals
from the retina into the superior
colliculus ideally under conditions
where we can still monitor some of these
looming reactions the superior
colliculus is a layered structure the
top layers receive inputs from retinal
ganglion cells the middle layers
actually get all kinds of multi-sensory
information there's some tactile
information there there's auditory and
even some olfactory signals and the
bottom layers of the superior colliculus
are already organized a bit more
towards motor output from the private
literature of course we know that it's
intimately involved in controlling and
aquatic eye movements in animals that do
less of that like rodents it is involved
apparently in directing animals towards
or away from objects in the environment
emulate in the bottom layers of the
superior colliculus and get things that
look like defensive reactions so what
we'd like to believe is that somewhere
in the structure there is a kind of
gradual processing of signals through
the layers that perhaps leads to a
refinement of these motor instructions
for defensive reactions near the bottom
layers taking two technical approaches
to this in both cases we have wake
behaving head fixed animals in one case
we window into the skull and image
neurons in the superior part of the the
top layers of the superior colliculus my
former postdoc Eman Feinberg developed a
method by which he can push and gently
nudge the cortex aside so as to reveal
about a square millimeter of superior
colliculus and that allows us to record
calcium signals from neurons in that
that top layer
Thorin's in the top layer of the
colliculus our respond strongly to
looming stimuli and much less so to one
of the control stimuli that is less
effective also in eliciting these
behavioral but as I said we'd really
like to understand what happens during
processing along vertical progression
through the superior colliculus and here
we started working with the silicon
prong electrodes they're just about long
enough to reach all the way from the top
to the bottom of this brain structure
and here's an example of a section in
which the fluorescent dye that was on
the silicon prong electrode got wiped
off so you can actually see where the
electrodes were located when we record
it from this animal let's give you a
glimpse of what happens there these are
completely raw electrode signals no
spike sorting done yet and so on but
just you can see how in
response to looming stimuli and the top
layers you get responses that repeat
more or less identically every time you
repeat this Hey
and then something interesting happens
in the bottom layers where suddenly
here's a neuron that recognizes only the
first display of that looming stimulus
and ignores subsequent ones so we're
very interested in finding out what kind
of filtering happens what kind of
salience the filtering occurs in these
circuits same thing with a white
expanding disk that we know is
ineffective in eliciting behaviors arns
are no longer interested Oren's on top
are still encoding that but this is just
a kind of a feel for how we'd like to go
about following these signals now
through the structure in the superior
colliculus making use of everything
we've learned about the retinal output
because that of course is the input
signal to this brain area so let me just
summarize again these are the major
questions that we'd like to go after we
think we've learned something about the
circuits that are involved in detection
or at least in feeding the detection
stage this how the decision is made is
still completely open and some things
about how the choice is modulated
through fraction with signals in the
hypothalamus that I'll tell you about
some other time but meanwhile let me
thank the people whose work I talked
about melih SEOmoz developed the
experiments on the looming behaviors she
took all the movies that I showed you
Brenna worked on the alpha retinal
ganglion cells even Feinberg developed
the optical approach to superior
colliculus electrical recordings I
mentioned at the very end our
collaborators moo-cow and Josh Saenz of
course were essential in everything I
talked about collaborations with the
David Anderson profit Kunwar are trying
to get at the kind of emotional
components of these
pensive reactions finally a bit of
shameless advertising there's still a
room in the lab it doesn't look quite
this empty anymore but there's still
space for your own experiments if you
want to join us
and these pictures were taken in January
so not completely reflective of what one
looks like today but anyway thank you
very much